Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. We are talking the fall of the Soviet Union. And in yesterday's episode, Dominic, we reached 1987, the 70th anniversary of the Russian Revolution. And how are things basically on the ground in the USSR at this point how is the anniversary being marked is there a sense of optimism of enthusiasm or just kind of disinterest or what's the mood so they're not going well so Gorbachev is um I mean this is such an immensely complicated story uh and I'm trying to sort of simplify it as much as possible so Gorbachev is slightly torn between
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory。我们正在讨论苏联的解体。而在昨天的节目中，多米尼克，我们讲到了1987年，也就是俄国革命爆发70周年。当时苏联国内的实际情况到底是怎样的？这个周年纪念是如何被庆祝的？人们是充满乐观和热情，还是仅仅感到冷漠，或者说当时的整体情绪究竟如何？所以，情况并不妙。因此，戈尔巴乔夫，呃——我的意思是，这是一个极其复杂的故事，呃，我正试图尽可能地把它简化——所以戈尔巴乔夫在某种程度上纠结于
two different camps he has the reformers who want him to go further faster and he has one of and the leading reformer is is this yet is boris yeltsin has he taken on that mantle by this well should we talk about him we can introduce boris yeltsin now now we're going to do boris yeltsin in the 1990s in a subsequent podcast because it's such a complicated and huge story and this is an absolutely fascinating thing because the relationship between these two men i mean this really is an example of individuals mattering in history tom because uh i think the relationship which is so ironic isn't it in the context it is the soviet union um the relationship between these two men and the way they don't get along is so crucial to this story had they got along the soviet union might well still exist and the war wow that's a big well he's brought he's brought in by gorbachev to be basically what the kind of
两个不同的阵营之间：他有希望他走得更远、更快的改革派，而其中一位、也是主要的改革派就是……叶利钦，鲍里斯·叶利钦。他当时已经挑起这副担子了吗？我们是不是该谈谈他？我们现在就可以介绍鲍里斯·叶利钦。当然，我们会在随后的播客中专门讲讲1990年代的鲍里斯·叶利钦，因为这是一个极其复杂且庞大的故事。而这绝对是一个引人入胜的话题，因为这两个人之间的关系——我的意思是，这真的是历史中“个人能发挥作用”的典型例证，汤姆，呃——我认为这种关系（在当时那种背景下显得如此具有讽刺意味，不是吗？那就是苏联），这两个人之间的关系以及他们合不来这件事，对整个故事至关重要。如果他们能合得来，苏联很可能直到今天依然存在。哇，这可真是个——噢，他被戈尔巴乔夫重用，基本上是为了担任某种类型的——
to run moscow exactly he's been in a place called sverdlovsk which is now which was called sverdlovsk at the time but it's ekaterinburg so it's the place where yes yeah yeah and where the romanovs were executed in the um uh in the urals, Yeltsin is a very different character from Gorbachev. Gorbachev is more idealistic and a kind of reader and all that sort of stuff, and a committee man, a man who loves tinkering with constitutions. Yeltsin is, as we all know, he's a bulliont. He's a populist.
去管理莫斯科，没错。他之前在一个叫斯维尔德洛夫斯克的地方，当时叫斯维尔德洛夫斯克，但现在是葉卡捷琳堡。所以那就是……对，对，对，罗曼诺夫王朝成员在乌拉尔山脉被处决的地方。叶利钦是一个与戈尔巴乔夫截然不同的人物。戈尔巴乔夫更具理想主义色彩，喜欢阅读诸如此类的事情，是个习惯通过委员会运作的人，一个热衷于琢磨宪法的人。而叶利钦，正如我们所知，他精力充沛，是个民粹主义者。
He likes a drink. He's great at glad-handing the crowd. He can be a bit of a club. He can be a drink. He's great at glad-handing the crowd. He can be a bit of a club. He can be a bully. He's this larger-than-life, incredibly impulsive figure. Yeltsin wants them to go faster. In 1987, so actually round about the time they're celebrating the anniversary of the October Revolution, Yeltsin says, I've had enough.
他喜欢喝一杯。他非常擅长与群众打成一片。他有时可能有点粗鲁。他可能会喝酒。他非常擅长与群众打成一片。他有时可能有点粗鲁。他可能会是个恶霸。他是一个生命力极其旺盛、极其冲动的人物。叶利钦希望他们能加快改革步伐。1987年，实际上差不多是在他们庆祝十月革命周年纪念的时候，叶利钦说：“我受够了。”
He's been attacked. He's very sort of sensitive, Yeltsin. So he's been attacked by hardliners, and he becomes the first person ever to resign from the Politburo. And Gorbachev is absolutely outraged by this, thinks this is terrible. And there's this sort of campaign against Yeltsin. Yeltsin, and this is not a story that a lot of people in the West, I think, are as familiar with as they should be.
他遭到了攻击。叶利钦是一个非常敏感的人。所以他受到了强硬派的攻击，并成为了历史上第一个从政治局辞职的人。戈尔巴乔夫对此感到极为愤怒，认为这太糟糕了。随后便展开了一场针对叶利钦的某种运动。叶利钦——这并不是一个许多西方人（我认为）应有的熟悉的故事——
Yeltsin tries to kill himself by stabbing himself in the chest with some scissors. He's taken to hospital and basically when he's in hospital being pumped full of drugs uh because people say he's gone mad and had a nervous breakdown uh gorbachev says you have to come to a party meeting moscow party meeting to be richly humiliated um this is so dostoevsky and he is i mean they take they pump him full of drugs. He comes out of hospital and he has to sit there while everybody else says, Boris Nikolaevich, you're a capitalist running dog or whatever they're saying. And he has to take it and he never forgives Gorbachev.
叶利钦试图用一把剪刀刺向自己的胸膛来杀害自己。他被送到医院，基本上当他躺在医院里被大量灌输药物时——呃，因为人们说他疯了、精神崩溃了——戈尔巴乔夫说：“你必须来参加一个党代会，莫斯科的党代会，好当众狠狠羞辱你一番。”呃，这太陀思妥耶夫斯基了！而他——我的意思是，他们给他注射了大量药物。他出院了，不得不坐在那里，听着其他所有人说：“鲍里斯·尼古拉耶维奇，你是个资本主义走狗，”或者诸如此类的话。他不得不忍受这一切，而且他永远不会原谅戈尔巴乔夫。
It's like the Brothers Karamazov. It is. It is. And he's determined, of course, to get his revenge. And that plays such a big part. Yeltsin feels completely and utterly humiliated. So he's out of the Politburo. Yeah, but he's not being kicked out of politics.
这就像《卡拉马佐夫兄弟》。确实如此。确实如此。而他当然决心要报复。这在其中起到了如此巨大的作用。叶利钦感到自己被彻头彻尾地羞辱了。所以他退出了政治局。是的，但他并没有被踢出政坛。
So he's still lurking around. Yes, exactly. He's still in the Communist Party. He's still sort of drifting around in political life. Now, the economic reforms are not going well at all. So you get the queues. They've always been queues, but they're getting longer and longer.
所以他依然潜伏在周围。是的，完全如此。他依然是共产党党员。他仍然在政治生活中若即若离。现在，经济改革一点也不顺利。于是你开始看到排长队。以前一直都有人在排队，但队伍变得越来越长。
There are shortages in the shops. There's also more and more problems in the other republics, kind of demonstrations and all this sort of stuff. And Dominic, is this, both with Perestroika, so the reorganization
商店里物资短缺。其他共和国也出现了越来越多的问题，比如游行示威之类的事情。多米尼克，这是不是因为无论是在“经济改革”（Perestroika）还是“公开性”（Glasnost）方面，
and Glasnost opening, is this because Gorbachev by 87, 88 is essentially, he's reached a kind of halfway house where he doesn't have the benefits of either. Exactly, Tom. Exactly. I mean, how often have you seen this with kind of Roman emperors or with kings or medieval kings that they, you have to choose. And Gorbachev thinks I have to keep my sort of foot in both camps he also to his credit in some ways he doesn't believe in violence I mean he he virtually he very rarely there are examples in Georgia and most famously in Lithuania where he uses troops to kind of repress uprisings
戈尔巴乔夫到87、88年时，基本上已经陷入了一种两头不讨好的中间地带？完全如此，汤姆。完全如此。我的意思是，你有多经常看到罗马皇帝、国王或中世纪的国王陷入这种境地——你必须作出抉择。而戈尔巴乔夫认为：“我必须在两个阵营里都留一只脚。”而且，从某些方面来说，值得赞赏的是，他不相信暴力。我的意思是，他几乎——他极少……虽然也有一些例子，比如在格鲁吉亚，以及最著名的在立陶宛，他动用了军队去镇压起义，
but by and large he doesn't like doing it and there are some historians I mentioned Vladislav Zubok who basically imply if he'd been tougher more ruthless if he'd accumulated more power instead of giving it away and he'd been quicker to use the sort of forces in order he didn't do it but he should have done it well that's how afraid the leading yeah story that's me about he should have been more rich than the third yeah yeah but what gorbachev does is he's been blocked and he says well the way to do it is to have even more democracy so he has this massive thing called the Congress of People's Deputies which he launches the plans for right summer of 88 is this akin to Charles I summoning a parliament
但总的来说，他并不喜欢这么做。正如我提到的历史学家弗拉迪斯拉夫·祖博克所暗示的那样，如果他更强硬、更冷酷，如果他积累了更多的权力而不是拱手让人，如果他能更快地使用某种武力——虽然他没有这么做，但他本该这么做的——这正是许多人对他的看法，认为他应该更强硬。但戈尔巴乔夫的做法是，当他四处受阻时，他说：“解决办法是实行更多的民主。”于是他搞了一个名为“人民代表大会”的庞大机构，并在1988年夏天推出了相关计划。这有点像查理一世召集议会
back after the years of personal rule or Louis XVI summoning um people to yeah the states general the states general to yeah it has a bit of that i suppose that i mean the congress of people's deputies is absolutely enormous they're gonna have like 2000 i think it's 2250 members um and from that that will choose a supreme soviet and he will also be personally elected for the first time as president not as general secretary so it's a way of kind of bypassing the party. It is, but it's properly democratic, right? I mean, there's a proper democratic element in a system
在经历多年的个人独裁之后，或者像路易十六召集三级会议一样？嗯，确实有点那种感觉。我是说，人民代表大会规模极其庞大，大概有2000，我想是2250名成员。从这些人当中将选出一个最高苏维埃，而且他本人也将首次以总统而非总书记的身份当选，所以这是一种绕过党内体制的方式。确实如此，但这可是真正的民主，对吧？我是说，这个体制中开始出现真正的民主元素
that hasn't had a democratic element like that for a very, very long time. So dissidents are elected. There are kind of nationalist figures from the Baltic states. There are people like Andrei Sakharov, the dissident scientist, very famous kind of figure in the West at this point. And there's Yeltsin. and there's yeltsin and there's yeltsin exactly so and and but tom what happens is it's also on telly it's on tv and this
这个体制已经很久很久没有过这样的民主元素了。因此，持不同政见者当选了，来自波罗的海三国的民族主义色彩人物当选了，还有像安德烈·萨哈罗夫这样在西方当时非常著名的持不同政见科学界人士，以及叶利钦。叶利钦，没错，就是叶利钦。但是，汤姆，最戏剧性的是这一切都在电视上直播，这在
is the first time this has ever happened and the bbc did a brilliant documentary about this many years ago i i can't for the life of me remember what it's called um and you can only see it on sort of very obscure websites because it's basically it was a brilliant kind of vibe if you like tv series about committees this is the one for you right so it's a sort of documentary and um they have all the sort of the footage and it's basically people are you know people arguing on platforms people standing up on the podium and saying you know we don't have enough food or this is a shambles boris is right about this, the General Secretary is right about that. I mean, it is a bit 1789, isn't it? People never did that.
历史上还是第一次。BBC多年前制作过一部关于这事的精彩纪录片，我怎么也想不起它叫什么名字了。你只能在一些非常冷门的网站上看到它，因为基本上——如果你喜欢关于委员会的精彩电视系列片，这就是为你准备的。所以它有点像纪录片，里面有各种素材，基本上就是人们在讲台上争论，人们站起来说“我们没有足够的食物”或者“一团糟，鲍里斯在这点上是对的，总书记在这点上也是对的”。我的意思是，这有点像1789年的法国大革命，不是吗？人们以前从不那样做。
There is an element of that. Yeah, there is. I think there probably is. People never did that. And it contributes to this sense of, I think, for a lot of Soviet citizens, just confusion. You know, what's going on? People arguing. Some people are delighted by the openness,
确实有那么一点成分。是的，确实有。我想可能确实如此。人们以前从不那样做。我认为这给许多苏联公民带来了一种困惑感：到底发生了什么？人们在争论。有些人对这种公开性感到欣喜，
but a lot of people are just confused by it. And, of course, what makes it more toxic is that it's against the background of this you know the system now has broken the interfering with the economic system has contributed to a situation where in 1989 in most parts of russia you now actually have meat rationing there is no sugar the the factories the fields and the collectives they're they're no longer supplying The factories, the fields, the collectives, they're no longer supplying the shops in the cities with what they need. But against that, by this point, you can read the Gulag Archipelago, can you not? You can indeed.
但许多人却对此感到困惑。当然，让情况更加恶化的是，这种背景是——你知道的，现在的体制已经崩溃了，对经济体制的干预导致了这样一种局面：到1989年，在俄罗斯的大多数地区，你实际上已经需要凭票购买肉类了，没有糖，工厂、农田和集体农庄不再向城市的商店供应它们所需的东西。然而与此相对的是，在这个时候，你可以读到《古拉格群岛》了，不是吗？确实可以。
Yeah, you can. This is the great dissident work by Solzhenitsyn. By Solzhenitsyn. But of course, a lot of people don't. This is the thing with them. I know. Of course, they don't want to read it. I mean, you'd rather have a steak or something.
是的，你可以读到了。这是索尔仁尼琴的不朽反体制著作。由索尔仁尼琴所著。但当然，很多人并没有读。这就是问题所在。我懂。当然，他们不想读。我是说，你宁愿去买块牛排什么的。
Yeah, they'd rather have some meat. But also, Tom, a lot of people, if you've been brought up to think one way all this time, and then you're suddenly told, well, what you thought was a lie, I mean, there's a very famous article published in 1988, which causes a huge hullabaloo by a woman called Nina Andreeva,
是的，他们宁愿吃点肉。但是，汤姆，许多人——如果你一直以来被灌输的是一种思维方式，然后突然有人告诉你，你过去以为的都是谎言——1988年发表过一篇非常著名的文章，由一个名叫尼娜·安德烈耶娃的女性所写，在苏联历史学家中非常知名，这篇文章引发了巨大的轰动
very well known to kind of Soviet historians, where she basically says, stop attacking Stalin. Because it's Stalin, right? Stop lying about our history. This kind of, you know, these wokest tearing down statues. Yes, yes. Because you said that for Gorbachev, it's all about Lenin. So therefore Stalin is cast as essentially the baddie,
她在文中基本上说：“别再攻击斯大林了。”因为那是斯大林，对吧？“别再篡改我们的历史了。”这有点像现在的“觉醒派”推倒雕像一样。是的，是的。因为你提到过，对戈尔巴乔夫来说，一切都关乎列宁。因此，斯大林基本上被塑造成了反派，
the guy who had come in and ruined it. You know, real communism hasn't been tried. This idea that, you know, what we've been living has been a bit of a lie and we've taken a wrong turn and we need to... A lot of people are just really... They're offended and upset and disturbed by that. They don't want to hear it.
那个介入并搞砸了一切的家伙。你知道的，“真正的共产主义还没有被尝试过”。这种观点认为，我们过去的生活是个谎言，我们走错了方向，我们需要……许多人真的对此感到愤怒、心烦和不安。他们根本不想听这些。
And of course it's easier to hear that when you can have some sugar. If there's no tea, no milk... I mean, what is it? 1989, 1990. hear that when you can have some sugar if there's no tea no milk i mean what is it 1989 1990 in in moscow that winter there is no milk no tea no coffee no soap meat is rationed you need to get to the shop but kind of when it opens all of this and against that background people think well this is all going horribly wrong so that's why by the the way, when the Berlin Wall falls and Eastern Europe, why there's so little Russian reaction, partly because Gorbachev doesn't believe in using force,
当然，当你能买到糖的时候，听这些话会容易得多。如果没有茶，没有牛奶……我的意思是，那是什么时候？1989年、1990年的莫斯科那个冬天，没有牛奶，没有茶，没有咖啡，没有肥皂，肉类凭票供应。你必须去商店排队等它开门，所有这些，在这样的背景下，人们觉得：这一切都在向极其糟糕的方向发展。所以这就是为什么柏林墙倒塌、东欧发生巨变时，俄罗斯人的反应却如此之小。部分是因为戈尔巴乔夫不相信使用武力，
it's partly because he's idealistic and he thinks, well, they'll stay in the socialist camp, because it's obviously a nicer kind of, kinder, more touchy-feely camp than the capitalist West. It's also because he and the others are so absorbed with their own colossal, colossal problems. And where is Putin? So Putin is still in Dresden. Putin is famously in Dresden when he burns his files, supposedly, when the Berlin Wall falls. He says to somebody, you know, we need to do something.
部分是因为他很理想主义，他认为他们会留在社会主义阵营里，因为这显然比资本主义西方更美好、更温情、更有人情味。这也是因为他和他的同僚们被他们自己极其庞大的问题缠身。那么普京在哪里呢？当时普京还在德累斯顿。众所周知，当柏林墙倒塌时，普京正在德累斯顿销毁文件。他曾对某个人说，我们需要做点什么。
And the guy says, well, we can't do anything without orders from Moscow. And he says some line, what is it? He says, Moscow is silent or something like that. Moscow says nothing. And for Putin, he later on says, he says supposedly after he becomes president, he says to some of his men, Russian history has produced two really bad, incompetent leaders.
那个人说，没有莫斯科的命令我们什么也做不了。他说了句台词，是什么来着？他说莫斯科沉默了，或者类似的话。莫斯科没有任何指示。普京后来曾说过——据称在他成为总统后，他对他的手下说：“俄罗斯历史产生了两个真正糟糕、不称职的领导人。
They were Nicholas II and Mikhail Sergeyevich Gorbachev because they were weak. They were weaklings. Whereas his two great heroes are Peter the Great and Stalin. Yeah. Well, I mean, that tells you what you need to know. Basically, don't rent your house out to Vladimir Putin, as we discovered in that party's podcast,
他们是尼古拉二世和米哈伊尔·谢尔盖耶维奇·戈尔巴乔夫，因为他们软弱。他们都是软弱的人。”而他心目中的两位伟大英雄则是彼得大帝和斯大林。是的。好吧，我的意思是，这说明了你需要知道的一切。基本上，不要把房子租给弗拉基米尔·普京，正如我们在那期播客中发现的那样，
because he'd smash it up, as like he's smashing up Ukraine. Right. So we're into 1990 now, Tom. The Warsaw Pact basically has drifted off. Has drifted off. Russia is moving towards this. The Soviet Union is moving towards this kind of multi-party politics. Industry is in a state of collapse. A lot of Gorbachev's sort of more reform-minded allies have deserted him because they think he's not going fast enough. But crucially,
因为他会把它砸个稀烂，就像他现在把乌克兰砸个稀烂一样。好了，汤姆，我们现在进入1990年了。华沙条约组织基本上已经名存实亡了。名存实亡了。俄罗斯正朝着这个方向发展。苏联正朝着多党政治的方向发展。工业处于崩溃状态。戈尔巴乔夫的一些倾向于改革的盟友也抛弃了他，因为他们觉得他行动不够快。但至关重要的是，
what's happening now is that the party elites and the people who run the state enterprises in the different republics are now beginning to think, you know, I don't want Gorbachev and this sort of shambolic interference in my affairs. And maybe I should be riding the tiger of kind of nationalism. So you start to see, I mean, obviously, be riding the tiger of kind of nationalism so you start to see i mean obviously you get the upsurge of nationalism in the baltic states because they remember you know that they were basically snatched by stalin and they want their freedom but other in other republics now the nationalism is becoming more and more of a thing and also within russia itself and well this is the fascinating thing.
现在发生的事情是，党内精英和各个共和国国营企业的负责人现在开始觉得：你知道吗，我才不要戈尔巴乔夫和这种对我事务的混乱干涉呢。或许我应该顺应民族主义这只猛兽。所以你开始看到——显而易见，你开始看到波罗的海三国民族主义的高涨，因为他们还记得，你知道的，他们基本上是被斯大林强行吞并的，他们想要自由。但在其他共和国，民族主义也越来越成为一个大问题，在俄罗斯本土也是如此。这真是个迷人的现象。
Boris Yeltsin becomes, in the spring of 1990, he becomes the elected leader of Russia. So Russia is 50-plus percent of the Soviet population. And like a lot of these republics, they're starting to declare their own sovereignty. They're saying, well, we are actually sovereign. We're not just kind of provinces of a soviet system we have our own you know our own personality our own kind of legal we're legal entities in our own right so yeltsin
在1990年春天，鲍里斯·叶利钦成为了俄罗斯的民选领导人。俄罗斯占苏联人口的50%以上。就像许多共和国一样，他们开始宣布自己的主权。他们说，其实我们是主权的拥有者。我们不仅仅是苏联体制下的几个省份，我们有自己的个性，有自己的法律地位，我们本身就是独立的法律实体。所以叶利钦
basically reformer he's capitalizing on people's frustration at the queues and stuff and their frustration with corruption and all these kinds of things yeltsin basically establishes russia as a as a counterweight to the soviet union so for the for the first time you get the sense i think 1990-91 of almost kind of parallel parallel governments they're competing for advisors they can have different economic programs all of this kind of stuff and there's a lightning rod for that, isn't there, in Vilnius? Yeah. So Vilnius is when he does use violence. That's the exception.
基本上作为一个改革派，他利用了人们对排队购物的沮丧情绪、对腐败的不满以及诸如此类的情绪。叶利钦基本上将俄罗斯确立为苏联的对立面。因此，在1990到1991年间，你第一次感觉到几乎出现了一种平行政府。他们在争夺顾问，制定不同的经济计划，诸如此类。而维尔纽斯事件成为了一个导火索，不是吗？是的。所以在维尔纽斯，他确实使用了暴力。那是唯一的例外。
Gorbachev does. Gorbachev does. And Yeltsin opposes it. And Yeltsin basically says to the Russian troops in the Baltic states, don't use violence. Yeah. So I think Yeltsin is much more of a kind of let them go. Gorbachev um is torn he he believes in the soviet union um he doesn't want to see anybody anybody leave the soviet union he hates violence but he's persuaded to use troops against the tv station
戈尔巴乔夫这样做了。戈尔巴乔夫这样做了。而叶利钦对此表示反对。叶利钦基本上对驻扎在波罗的海三国的俄罗斯军队说：不要使用暴力。所以我想叶利钦更倾向于“让他们走”。而戈尔巴乔夫则陷入了纠结，他信仰苏联，他不希望看到任何人离开苏联，他痛恨暴力，但他却被说服派遣军队对付电视台
of illness and they kill 15 people um and it's against that kind of background so you get so you've got economic meltdown you have a loss of political authority you have the sort of the public bewildered and stuff that that um gorbachev says well listen i mean he's messed around with the constitution so much already but he says you know a new change we're going to have a new union treaty. So replacing kind of 1922, which we talked about in our 1922 podcast at the beginning of the year, we're going to have a new union treaty and that'll be signed in August. All the republics will sign it. And it's basically signing up to a new model, more slightly more decentralized model of the Soviet Union.
在维尔纽斯，他们杀害了15人。正是在这种背景下——经济彻底崩塌，政治权威丧失，公众感到困惑不解等等——戈尔巴乔夫说，听着，他已经把宪法搞得够乱了，但他宣布：“我们要有一个新的变化，我们要签署一份新的联盟条约。”用来取代我们在今年初的1922年播客中讨论过的1922年条约，我们将签署一份新的联盟条约，这将在8月签署。所有共和国都会签署。这基本上是签署加入一个新模式，一个稍微去中心化一点的苏联模式。
Kind of like we're reaffirming our vows, basically. Now that's against the background. That summer, there is a total kind of collapse in the in the economy so industry collapses by 18 agriculture by 17 they're running a massive deficit now they can't afford to import consumer goods at that point there is a road not taken um which you sometimes hear talk about in the West. So there is talk in the summer of 1991 of George Bush Sr.'s administration intervening with a kind of Marshall Plan
就像我们基本上在重申我们的誓言一样。然而，这样的背景是，那年夏天，经济彻底崩溃了。工业产值下降了18%，农业下降了17%，他们正面临巨额赤字，此时他们已经无力进口消费品了。当时有一条“未选择的路”，你在西方有时会听到人们谈论它。
for the Soviet Union. And I think there is a case that this is a great what if. Because there's a guy- So what would have happened? Well, there's a guy called Grigory Lavlinsky, who's a Russian reformer, and he cooks up a scheme with a Harvard academic called Graham Allison. And that's basically to lend the Soviet Union billions or to give the Soviet Union billions of dollars and establish them as a partner to basically bail Gorbachev out.
因此，在1991年夏天，有传言称老乔治·布什政府将以某种类似马歇尔计划的形式介入苏联事务。
And Bush says, no, Congress won't back it. We're not in the business of flushing money down the drain, which is what will happen. The Soviet Union is a communist country. What are we doing? All this kind of stuff. They don't back it we're not in the business of flushing money down the drain which is what will happen you know the soviet union is a communist country what are we doing all this kind of stuff they don't do what would have happened who can say tom i mean maybe i i think gorbachev had lost so much political authority by that point already that actually that would have been money down the drain brutally yeah um certainly wouldn't have said i don't think it would have saved gorbachev probably wouldn wouldn't, might not have saved the Soviet Union either. But it might have cushioned Russia's transition to democracy. Okay, let's take a quick break there
而布什说，国会不会支持的。我们不是在把钱扔进水里，那样做的话结果只会是这样。苏联是个共产主义国家。我们在干什么？诸如此类的话。他们没有提供支持。我们可不是在把钱往下水道里倒，因为这正是会发生的事情，你知道的，苏联是个共产主义国家，我们到底在干什么？诸如此类的事情。他们没有采取行动。如果当时采取了会怎样？谁说得准呢，汤姆？我的意思是，也许——我认为戈尔巴乔夫到那个时候已经失去了太多的政治权威，实际上那些钱投进去也是打水漂，说得残忍一点，是的。而且这肯定无法拯救戈尔巴乔夫，可能也无法拯救苏联。但它或许能缓和俄罗斯向民主过渡的阵痛。好了，我们先休息一下
and we will see you after some ads or not after some ads if you are members of our The Rest Is History Club. Whatever format you're listening, we will be back with you very soon. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
稍后在广告之后再见，如果你是我们的“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员，则无需听广告。无论你通过什么平台收听，我们很快就会回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestistertainment.com. That's TheRestIsEntertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Gorbachev is trying, struggling to keep the Soviet Union together. Does Yeltsin have a feeling it would be better for Russia to get rid of all these kind of various deadbeats as he sees them, these appendages to Mother Russia? Is that his attitude? Some people may think, listening to this, may think, gosh, this has got a bit of kind of a United Kingdom sort of arguments about devolution and Scottish or Welsh independence kind of vibe to it.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦以及在我们的问答环节中揭开娱乐业幕后运作原理的独家大餐。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisenterthetainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisenterthetainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。戈尔巴乔夫正在努力、挣扎着维持苏联的统一。叶利钦是否觉得，对俄罗斯来说，摆脱所有这些在他看来是累赘、是俄罗斯母亲附庸的各共和国会更好？这是他的态度吗？听众听到这里可能会想：天哪，这有点像英国关于权力下放以及苏格兰或威尔士独立的争论那种调调。
Because definitely there are people now in Russia for the first time who are sort of saying, do we need all these Islamic republics in Central Asia? You know, they're just... The problem, though, is that 25 million Russian speakers live outside Russia. I mean, that's the context for the world we're living in now. That it's a bit like, know germany um we'll get
因为俄罗斯国内现在确实第一次有人在问：我们需要中亚所有这些伊斯兰共和国吗？你知道，它们只是……然而问题在于，有2500万俄罗斯语人口生活在俄罗斯境外。我的意思是，这就是我们今天所处世界的背景。这就有点像德国……我们将在下一期关于魏玛共和国相似之处的播客中深入探讨这一点
into this in the next podcast about the weimar republic parallels but there's that is a problem uh but yeltsin is i think yeltsin that the sense i get from this a lot of the books on this is that yeltsin is completely fixated on his rivalry with gorbachev and he's not thinking kind of particularly strategically about russia's future in the next 20 or 30 years. He's thinking, how can I establish myself as the sort of primus inter pares instead of Gorbachev? Dominic, it's not just Gorbachev against Yeltsin, is it? Because there are also lurking in the background
但这是一个问题。不过，叶利钦——我从关于这主题的大量书籍中体会到的是，叶利钦完全沉迷于他与戈尔巴乔夫的权力争夺中，并没有对俄罗斯未来二三十年的发展做出特别具战略性的思考。他考虑的是：我如何取代戈尔巴乔夫，让自己成为同辈中的第一人？多米尼克，这不仅仅是戈尔巴乔夫与叶利钦的对抗，对吧？因为在幕后还潜伏着
communist hardliners. Yeah. And in August 1991, they launched basically an incredibly incompetent coup but i remember uh walking through london and seeing kind of newspaper billboard saying coup in moscow and thinking oh god yeah um again because a bit like the headlines at the moment um this was a headline that could have come from an alternative reality novel in which you know the world gets blown up or something so i'm being very nervous i'm a bit younger than you
共产主义强硬派。是的。在1991年8月，他们基本上发动了一场极其无能的政变。但我记得我走过伦敦街头，看到报纸广告牌上写着“莫斯科发生政变”，心里想：天哪，是的。又来了，就像当前的头条新闻一样，这是一个可能出自架空历史小说、世界将会毁灭之类的头条新闻。所以我当时非常紧张，我比你年轻一点
my my mum woke me up to tell me the news um just sort of first thing in the morning so that was uh gorbachev being arrested in his dacha wasn't yeah he'd gone but he'd gone to foros in the crimea where he went on holiday and um one day, so it's two days actually before they're going to sign the new union treaty. And the hardliners think this will give away so much power for everyone, we'll never get it back. So they cut off his telephones, they pitch up, they kind of basically want him to resign. He doesn't want to do it.
我妈妈把我叫醒告诉我这个消息，就在一大清早。所以那是——戈尔巴乔夫在达恰被软禁了，对吧？他去了克里米亚的福罗斯度假，就在他们准备签署新联盟条约的两天前。强硬派认为这会把太多的权力让给各方，他们将再也拿不回来。于是他们切断了他的电话，闯了进去，基本上是逼他辞职。但他不肯这样做。
They form a state emergency committee. As you say, it's complete shambles. They don't arrest Yeltsin. They don't take control of communications. They don't take control of the Russian streets. And Yeltsin has his moment in history. I mean, they've handed it to him on a platter, and he seizes it with this,
他们组成了国家紧急状态委员会。正如你所说，这完全是一场闹剧。他们没有逮捕叶利钦，没有控制通信，也没有控制俄罗斯的街道。而叶利钦迎来了属于他的历史时刻。我的意思是，他们把政权拱手送到他手上，而他紧紧抓住了这个
because we said before he was a bullion, populist character. I mean, anyone who lived through this will remember those incredible scenes. You know, Yeltsin gets on a tank. He commandeers a tank. There's amazing photos. The tank driver's got
因为我们之前说过，他是个身材魁梧、极具民粹主义色彩的人物。我的意思是，任何经历过那个时期的人都会记得那些难以置信的场景。你知道，叶利钦爬上一辆坦克。他强行征用了坦克。有很棒的照片。坦克的驾驶员把
his head in his hands because you know he's basically been humiliated yeltsin has seized his tank it's a great crowd around him he reads a proclamation in which he says you know this is a coup of reactionaries and all this um he he he takes possession of the russian part the russian parliament building not the soviets not the building on the Kremlin, but a building called the White House, ironically, the Russian parliament. And for a couple of days, it looks like the coup plotters are going to storm the White House and kill Yeltsin,
头埋在手里，因为你知道他基本上被羞辱了，叶利钦夺取了他的坦克，他周围聚集了巨大的人群，他宣读了一份公告，在公告中他说，你知道，这是一场反动派的政变，诸如此类，嗯，他占领了俄罗斯部分，俄罗斯议会大楼，不是苏维埃，不是克里姆林宫的那栋建筑，而是一栋讽刺性地被称为白宫的建筑，也就是俄罗斯议会。在几天的时间里，政变策划者似乎要冲进白宫并杀死叶利钦，
but they don't have the guts. They're all absolutely hammered or shaking or just sort of sweating and gibbering in their various offices. They don't have a plan. They don't have a heavy uniform yeah well they're they're actually if you look at the the footage i always remember the footage the leader was a guy called ganada yanaev and he was shaking when he read that well he was the front man he wasn't the leader he was shaking when he read his proclamation they're all wearing the most terrible suits i mean those suits in themselves are a very bad advert for the Soviet system.
但他们没有这个胆量。他们全都喝得酩酊大醉、浑身发抖，或者只是在各自的办公室里出汗和胡言乱语。他们没有计划。他们没有厚重的制服，好吧，其实如果你看镜头，我总是记得那个镜头，领导人是一个叫根纳季·亚纳耶夫的家伙，他读那份公告时浑身发抖，好吧，他是前台人物，他不是领导人，他读他的公告时浑身发抖，他们都穿着最糟糕的西装，我的意思是，这些西装本身就是对苏联制度的一个非常糟糕的广告。
Supposedly, this is the moment when Putin resigned from the KGB. I mean, I say resigned. I mean, there's a question about whether he ever left the KGB. But later in his sort of his sort of, you know, as it were official biography, it was claimed that this was the point where he broke with communism.
据说，这就是普京辞去克格勃职务的时刻。我是说，我说辞职。我的意思是，关于他是否真的离开过克格勃，一直存在疑问。但在他后来的某种，某种，你知道的，所谓的官方传记中，有人声称这就是他与共产主义决裂的时刻。
Putin. But I mean, whether that's true, none none of us to to side with yeltsin yes well we'll we'll we'll get into how putin and yeltsin form their relationship in the in the next podcast um but yes it's it's just impossible to say what putin's position all this is i mean my sense is that he's not there at the white house with Yeltsin on the tanker. No, no, no. I mean, he's watching from the distance. Yes, he is watching from a distance. So, okay.
普京。但我的意思是，不管这是不是真的，我们谁也不会站在叶利钦一边，好吧，我们会在下一个播客中讨论普京和叶利钦是如何建立关系的，嗯，但是是的，根本无法说明普京对这一切的立场是什么，我的感觉是，他没有和叶利钦一起在坦克上出现在白宫。不，不，不。我的意思是，他在远处看着。是的，他在远处看着。所以，好吧。
Gorbachev, the Ku Klux lose their nerve. Gorbachev returns from the Crimea. And then we talked about the humiliation for Yeltsin. Now it's his turn, his chance to turn the tables. And, you know, again again incredible that this was played out live on television he basically um gets Gorbachev to to a meeting of the Russian Supreme Soviet uh so so they're basically the government that Yeltsin controls and he says you know live in front he says here's a list of all the people your aides your appointees who collaborated in the coup read it out and he makes Gorbachev read it out in front of this audience terribly humiliating
戈尔巴乔夫，克格勃失去了勇气。戈尔巴乔夫从克里米亚返回。然后我们谈到了对叶利钦的羞辱。现在轮到他了，这是他扭转局面的机会。而且，你知道，再次，再次令人难以置信的是，这是在电视上直播的，他基本上，嗯，让戈尔巴乔夫参加俄罗斯最高苏维埃的一个会议，嗯，所以他们基本上是叶利钦控制的政府，他说，你知道，在现场直播面前，他说，这里有一份所有人的名单，你的助手，你的任命人员，他们在政变中串通一党，把它读出来，他让戈尔巴乔夫在这些观众面前把它读出来，这非常具有羞辱性
and then Yeltsin just suddenly has the momentum he bans the communist party in Russia he says we're going to move to a market economy you know immediately we're going to have you know shock therapy is looming nobody knows what that means at this point but he says you know i have the economic sort of medicine that will fix that the what's gone now alternative yes very that's right but at the same time this is the point when the various republics start to go their own way so yeltsin says yeah fine let the baltic states go um the the real question is ukraine so the leader in ukraine a man called Leonid Kravchuk, is the classic example of somebody who all his life has just been a complete apparatchik.
然后叶利钦突然占据了势头，他在俄罗斯取缔了共产党，他说我们要立即转向市场经济，你知道，休克疗法即将来临，此时没有人知道这意味着什么，但他说，你知道，我有能解决这个问题的经济类药物，现在已经没有替代方案了，是的，非常正确，但与此同时，这也是各个共和国开始走自己道路的时刻，所以叶利钦说，好吧，没问题，让波罗的海国家走吧，嗯，真正的问题是乌克兰，所以乌克兰的领导人，一个叫列昂尼德·克拉夫丘克的人，是一个典型的例子，他一生都只是一个彻头彻尾的官僚。
And now, you know, he doesn't want, he wants to hold onto his power. He wants to hold onto the control with his mates of the state enterprises and stuff. And so he jumps onto the Ukrainian nationalist bandwagon. He declares Ukrainian sovereignty and he declares a referendum for the 1st of December 1991. Why does he do this?
现在，你知道，他不想，他想保住自己的权力。他想和他的伙伴们一起保住对国有企业等的控制权。因此，他跳上了乌克兰民族主义的潮流。他宣布乌克兰主权，并宣布在1991年12月1日举行公投。他为什么要这样做？
The answer is, I think, because he looks at those two people, Gorbachev and Yeltsin, and he thinks if Gorbachev wins, Gorbachev will sort of, you know, Kravchuk had equivocated during the coup. He thinks if Gorbachev wins, Gorbachev will basically, you know, Kravchuk had equivocated during the coup. He thinks if Gorbachev wins, Gorbachev will basically, you know, it's not good for us. He'll mess with us and our system and our privileges and stuff and our control of all this stuff.
答案是，我认为，因为他看着那两个人，戈尔巴乔夫和叶利钦，他认为如果戈尔巴乔夫赢了，戈尔巴乔夫会，你知道的，克拉夫丘克在政变期间曾含糊其辞。他认为如果戈尔巴乔夫赢了，戈尔巴乔夫会基本上，你知道的，克拉夫丘克在政变期间曾含糊其辞。他认为如果戈尔巴乔夫赢了，戈尔巴乔夫会基本上，你知道的，这对我们没有好处。他会干涉我们、我们的体制、我们的特权以及我们对所有这些东西的控制。
If Yeltsin, you know, I don't want to be stuck with Yeltsin commandeering it for Russia and sort of, you know, him taking it over. So the best thing is basically we take it over ourselves and we'll control it ourselves. And I think a lot of the, so if you look at the first post-independence leaders and all those Soviet republics in Central Asia and so on, they're all the people generally
如果叶利钦，你知道，我不想被叶利钦困住，让他为俄罗斯争夺控制权，并某种程度上，你知道，让他接管。所以最好的办法基本上是我们自己接管，我们自己控制。我认为很多，所以如果你看看第一批独立后的领导人和中亚等地的所有这些苏联共和国，他们基本上都是那些人
who are running the Communist Party in those places beforehand. And the same thing happens in Belarus, right? Exactly. And Yeltsin and the belarus and uh ukrainian leaders all meet up in a in a wood hunting lodge yeah in a forest yeah in the forest in in belarus yeah so they go to um a place called belavezha um as you know tom i'm i've been to belarus myself yes i'm great admirer of its chocolate so they meet up and they basically the leaders of these three
在此之前，他们在这些地方管理共产党。白俄罗斯也是如此，对吧？完全正确。叶利钦、白俄罗斯和乌克兰领导人在一个木头狩猎小屋里会面，是的，在森林里，是的，在白俄罗斯的森林里，是的，所以他们去了一个叫别洛韦日的地方，如你所知，汤姆，我自己去过白俄罗斯，是的，我是它巧克力的忠实崇拜者，所以他们见面了，基本上这三位领导人
republics behind gorbachev's back they sign a deal they'll all become independent they'll have a very loose association called the Commonwealth of Independent States and you know that's it bang goes the Soviet Union nobody in the Soviet Union by and large well 20% of the people in the Soviet Union want this 80% do not want this so this is not happening as a result of massive public protests it's not happening because after years of you know mounting sort of passions and and street violence it's happening largely because of rivalries and desire for self-protection among different parts of the of the soviet elite well we talked about the collapse of the roman empire and the way that um it you know in the west in the fifth century chunks of it start splitting off because local bigwigs start to appreciate that they're likely to have more
在戈尔巴乔夫背后，共和国签署了一项协议，他们都将获得独立，他们将建立一个名为“独立国家联合体”的非常松散的联盟，你知道，就这样，苏联完蛋了。苏联几乎没有人，好吧，苏联20%的人想要这个，80%的人不想要这个，所以这不是大规模公众抗议的结果，也不是多年来不断升级的激情和街头暴力的结果，它发生主要是因为苏联精英不同部分之间的竞争和自我保护的欲望，嗯，我们谈到了罗马帝国的崩溃以及它在西方五世纪开始分裂的方式，因为当地的大人物开始意识到他们更有可能拥有
authority more wealth more position if they go independent and you're essentially saying it's much the same thing is happening happening in the Soviet Union. It is actually a remarkably... It's kind of barons carving up territory. It is barons carving up territory. Interestingly, I was just reading this book today, the Zubov book, Collapse. He says he has stuff in that
如果他们独立，他们就会获得更多的权威、更多的财富、更多的地位，你基本上是在说，苏联也发生了大致相同的事情。这其实非常……这有点像诸侯瓜分领土。这确实是诸侯瓜分领土。有趣的是，我今天刚好在读这本书，祖博夫的书《崩溃》。他说他里面有内容
that I'd not seen before. There are people around Yeltsin who say to him that December 1991, are you just going to go and say yes to the Ukrainian guy? What about Crimea? What about Donbass? I mean, they literally say these places. And he says, oh, I may mention it, yeah.
我以前没见过。叶利钦身边有人对他说，1991年12月，你打算就这样去对乌克兰人说“好”吗？克里米亚怎么办？顿巴斯怎么办？我的意思是，他们字面意思上提到了这些地方。而他说，哦，我可能会顺便提一下，是的。
And he doesn't mention it because he's just so keen to get one over on Gorbachev. And that's the reason, not because he's drunk. Well, there is a bit of drinking. There definitely is a bit of drinking. And actually at that meeting, I think there was some talk of drinking there definitely is a bit of drinking and actually at that meeting i think there was some talk of kelton having it carried out yeah not having to be carried out but yeah it's easy to stereotype yeltsin i mean yeltsin is a is a tremendous
他没有提到它，因为他太急于战胜戈尔巴乔夫了。这就是原因，而不是因为他喝醉了。好吧，确实喝了点酒。绝对是喝了点酒。事实上，在那个会议上，我 tror 当时好像有人谈论喝酒，绝对是喝了点酒，而且事实上在那个会议上，我记得到处都有关于叶利钦让人把酒搬来的讨论，是的，不用让人搬来，但是是的，要把叶利钦刻板化很容易，我的意思是，叶利钦是一个了不起的
politician as a populist as a communicator and stuff and he has had this sort of very stressful time he has been very brave but you're right there is the there is always the issue the drink he's so fixated i think i'm beating gorbachev so they get back it's such an amazing psychodrama and it's it is actually someone should write a you know do a film i know and the fate of you know hundreds of millions of people hangs on this they get back he goes they get back to moscow and they're basically gorbachev's like what and they say yeah the soviet union is no more we've decided to leave. And then, of course, everybody else decides to leave as well. And they say, oh, we'll join this new Commonwealth of Independent States.
政客，作为一个民粹主义者、沟通者等等，他经历了这样一段压力巨大的时期，他非常勇敢，但你说得对，这里总是存在酒精的问题，他太专注于，我想我是击败了戈尔巴乔夫，所以他们回来了，这是一个如此惊人的心理剧，实际上应该有人写一个，（拍一部电影），我知道，数亿人的命运悬于一线，他们回来后，他去了，他们回到莫斯科，戈尔巴乔夫基本上是一脸震惊，他们说，是的，苏联不复存在了，我们决定离开。然后，当然，其他人也决定离开。他们说，哦，我们将加入这个新的独立国家联合体。
And that's all the cool kids have moved on. Basically, Gorbachev is there in the Kremlin. No one listens to him. The army have stopped listening to him. The interior ministry troops don't listen to him. The police don't listen to him. It's like Romulus Augustulus. It is exactly that, Tom.
所有时髦的孩子都已经前行了。基本上，戈尔巴乔夫就坐在克里姆林宫里。没有人听他的。军队不再听他的了。内政部部队不听他的了。警察不听他的了。这就像罗慕路斯·奥古斯图ulus。完全就是这样，汤姆。
We did this story on the 12 Days of Christmas podcast on the 25th of December 1991. That's the day that Gorbachev resigns as president of the USSR, that the flag comes down, the hammer and sickness replaced by the Russian tricolor on the sort of Kremlin flagpole. That's the day the Soviet Union ends and the Russian Federation comes into existence. And we did this on our 12 Days of History podcast. But the worst thing about it is not actually the well-known fact that Gorbachev was filmed by American cameramen and he had to borrow a pen from the CNN producer to sign his resignation. A capitalist pen. A capitalist pen.
我们在1991年12月25日的“圣诞节12天”播客中报道了这个故事。那是戈尔巴乔夫辞去苏联总统职务的日子，旗帜降下来，锤子镰刀被克里姆林宫旗杆上的俄罗斯三色旗所取代。那是苏联结束、俄罗斯联邦诞生的日子。我们在我们的“历史12天”播客中做了这个。但最糟糕的不是众所周知的事实，即戈尔巴乔夫被美国摄像师拍了下来，他不得不借用CNN制片人的笔来签署他的辞职信。一支资本主义的笔。一支资本主义的笔。
There's actually a worse fact than that, which I didn't mention on that last podcast, which is that there's a ceremony where he basically hands over the nuclear briefcase to um to boris yeltsin or gives it to somebody to give to yeltsin but actually in secret they'd already switched the briefcases so gorbachev thought at the end of that he was walking around with the nuclear briefcase but he wasn't it had been taken away from him behind his back already and um don't piss off the cool guys and uh yeah so to go back to putin putin is back in russia um he watches this with with horror for him as he later says the collapse of the soviet union he's called it the greatest geopolitical catastrophe of the century. And it is
实际上还有一个比这更糟糕的事实，我在上期播客中没有提到，那就是有一个仪式，他基本上把核公文包交给了……呃，交给了鲍里斯·叶利钦，或者交给某人转交给叶利钦，但实际上他们私下里已经调换了公文包，所以戈尔巴乔夫以为在那个仪式结束时，他身上还带着核公文包，其实并没有，早在他的背后，公文包就已经被拿走了，呃，千万别惹那些冷酷的家伙，呃，所以回到普京身上，普京回到了俄罗斯，他带着恐惧注视着这一切，对他来说，正如他后来所说，苏联的解体，他称之为本世纪最大的地缘政治灾难。确实如此。
an extraordinary moment because at a stroke, the empire that had been inherited by the communists from the Tsars fragments. The 15 republics go their own way. Suddenly, there is this nation state called Russia that has 88 different federal subjects in it so it has lots of muslims it has chechens tatars tuvans all kinds of people in the kind of um in the in the steps and the forests of the east and suddenly it's a nation state that feels like it's lost colossal amounts of status and also has lots of its citizens outside its borders. Lots of people who maybe either think they're Russian or speak Russian. Exactly. Okay. Well, so what a dramatic moment. The Soviet Union has come to an end. Russia has been born. Yeltsin has replaced Gorbachev.
这是一个非同寻常的时刻，因为就在转瞬之间，共产党从沙皇那里继承的帝国四分五裂。15个加盟共和国各自走自己的路。突然之间，出现了一个名为俄罗斯的民族国家，里面有88个不同的联邦主体，所以里面有很多穆斯林，有车臣人、鞑靼人、图瓦人，在东部的草原和森林里有各种各样的人，突然之间，这个民族国家感觉自己失去了巨量的地位，而且其国境之外还有大量的公民。有很多人可能认为自己是俄罗斯人或者说俄语。没错。好的。所以，这是一个多么戏剧性的时刻。苏联走向了终结。俄罗斯诞生了。叶利钦取代了戈尔巴乔夫。
Putin is kind of swimming in the shallows like a kind of baby shark waiting to taste a bit more blood and I think we should leave it there and tomorrow's episode we should see what happens under Yeltsin and how it is that Putin ends up becoming president see you again tomorrow thanks very much bye-. Bye-byeishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
普京就像一条小鲨鱼一样在浅水区游弋，等待着尝到更多血腥味，我想我们今天就聊到这里，明天的节目里，我们将看看叶利钦治下发生了什么，以及普京是如何最终成为总统的，我们明天再见，非常感谢，再见-. Bye-byeishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的固定去处，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有一点娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外期节目以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。